[Musique]
bonjour à toute la planète et si tu
aimes tant le canada en direct de
montréal
bientôt on l'appellera tente à montréal
mais en attendant on a plaisir de vous
accueillir avec sous la fraîcheur de
l'hiver c'est une des journées les plus
froides non seulement ici à montréal
mais sans doute dans l'ouest canadien
havel est aussi les problèmes ont froid
ben oui oui à calgary l'ont été ils ont
été rentrés dans le zoo et les ont ils
les ont rentré dans les bâtisses là
alors on a rentré dans le bois dans
l'émission voici pour nous réchauffer un
peu les collègues dans sa mère brenda
faire dans la israel ou dc bonjour bravo
et bonjour ici stéphane parent alors
bienvenue à cette émission encore une
fois vous n'avez pas idée du sujet non
vous allez voir ça va être un beau sujet
pour le temps dès l'hiver j'ai dit au
temps des fêtes mais c'est passé bon
alors on y va on va allonger la vie au
numéro et avant de la regarder je fais
juste rassurer nos auditeurs que la non
présence de femmes aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas du tout un coup d'état masculinistes
quoique ce soit c'est jusque là vous
avez raté la première image que vous
n'avez vu oui je l'avais lu moi ça m
cinq images pour vous décider quel est
le sujet aujourd'hui les missions et les
feux de forêt en australie
l'échauffement climatique
c'est bon ajout de mathématiques j'aime
beaucoup par une catastrophe dit que
rare c'est bien le mot catastrophe les
gestion des catastrophes gestion des
catastrophes a vendu vous travaillez
bien non il faut qu'ils ont fait aux
écoutes et ben voilà ça va réchauffer un
peu aujourd'hui
la hausse du coût des catastrophes
là il faut en parler on va établir des
parallèles entre la situation en
australie la situation au canada nous
avons nous sommes aux antipodes
nous avons des problèmes communs même
que nous pourrions nous entraider et on
va parler de ça avec deux spécialistes
notamment un de la gestion des crises au
canada un grand spécialiste
on va découvrir ensemble que la
responsabilité du futur nous un cas on à
nous quatre simples citoyens les le
gouvernement pourrait ne pas pouvoir
faire les frais du réchauffement et
éventuellement tous les frais en tout
cas on va faire ce responsable pas ni
d'assurance j'espère qu'elles ne feront
jamais fait non ça c'est sûr alors on
regarde ça ensemble j'ai pour vous
préparer avant d'aller vers notre
premier invité deux premiers
spécialistes
vous savez on a trois jeux à l'émission
grâce à la grosse boule on lance on y va
la première boule aller il ya cent bus
la terre par émission pour le premier je
viens vous la perdre et avant d'aller
vers la question comme tel je pense que
j'ai préparé pour vous quelque chose
d'amusant
c'est pour vous mettre dans le bain un
peu plus à aider ceux qui nous regardent
à l'extérieur du canada ou même
aujourd'hui à l'extérieur de montréal
qui n'auraient pas une idée de la
géographie canadienne parce qu'on va
beaucoup parler de géographie
aujourd'hui c'est le thème est bien
attention chaque question aujourd'hui
bâtie sur la précédente c'est un peu
comme les tests bleus mathématiques à
l'école c'est vraiment le tranport
premier virage alors on y va pour la
première je vous présente une image
c'est notre vidéo numéro 2 ça vous donne
une idée de la grandeur de l'île de
montréal parce que ça va être important
dans la première question
cette candeur la jeu on va montrer l'île
de montréal à quoi ça ressemble c'est
pas tout ce que vous voyez des trains on
va encerclé sa hausse et où nous on vous
parle en ce moment pas loin de longueuil
et puis on fait tout le tour de l'île de
montréal pour ceux qui nous ont jamais
eu le temps de le faire en vélo dans la
là ça descend jusqu'en bas de la carte
si par malheur au port du voile a donc
on a grandi un peu la carte pour vous
donner une idée voici un petit on
présente à l'écran la première de nos
deux questions aujourd'hui la superficie
de la forêt australienne qui est parti
en fumée et qui voit en ce moment à
combien de fois celle de l'île de
montréal
ah ah d'accord est-ce que c'est à 50
fois
est ce que c b st foy ou est ce que
c'est c'est 200 fois partis en fumée ça
veut vraiment cette bulle moi c'est 200
x 200 mois c'est énorme les feux qui ont
ravagé oui il ya des attaques des sacs
entiers de sang alors on va acter jeux
2d c'est un souvent en répondant parce
qu'on sait pas trop con répandre ben moi
je pense que c'est impressionnant donc
je prends le chiffre le plus
impressionnant impression mais après de
la moralité on a en a combien de
secondes qui reste pour la rivale en
trois mois pour qu'il y ait deux
réponses différentes mesures et pour son
image in man rien sauf que ce qu'on nous
a montré c'est vraiment il faut répondre
là vous avez 60 secondes de répondre
vous avez déjà épuisé 59 selon as les
deux sens qu'est le sang - gérer pour
105 x donc b alors si vous voyez un
astérix apparaître au delà au niveau de
votre réponse vous avoue qu'on donc je
pars va c'est ça vous avez perdu
seulement parfait rien de grave
la trame est 200 fois c'est incroyable
ça oui c'est le calcul et 5 500
kilomètres carrés
l'île de montréal à peu près on enlève
peut-être mille kilomètres pour arrondir
et la basse et 5000 kilomètres carrés
sens qu'il donne ça donne 100 sur 1100
un cas un rectangle de 100 kilomètres
sur michael rogers professeur de
mathématiques et un demi million
d'espèces ou si c'est un chiffre qui ont
inspiré ce passe en parle de ses membres
oui j'ai vu entendu parler d'un milliard
oui mais après ça va des quotas comptait
pas sans baisser c'est assurément une
catastrophe à la fois écologie mali
c'est naturel
c'est humain c'est qu'ils allaient koala
qui demande à quiconque a un qui en
donne de l'eau comme ça les images
étaient très les kangourous c'est pas
fini la mois de février pour les plus
jeunes ils ont eu des récemment un peu
de pluie l'ambiance en fait une truie
mais comme je dis stéphane la saison
estivale elle commence ce n'est que le
début d'une plus grande catastrophe
malheureusement quand c'est l'été là bas
c'est l'hiver ici et vice versa la balle
est toujours et puis les canadiens les
australiens peuvent s'aider mutuellement
au niveau de leur expertise parce que
les projets envoyé une équipe pour
gestion pour la gestion des dépôts
incendies des exploits les incendies je
ne sais pas les pompiers avec des tuyaux
ce n'est pas des gros bras et une
expertise comme un droit des feux à
chaque été aussi ocana dans l'alberta la
colombie-britannique et toucher toujours
par des incendies très fortes rafales de
la centre deux incendies à fort mcmurray
en alberta
ça me donne une idée on essaie de
présenter des images de sa zone instant
de jus d'accord on va aller vers notre
spécialiste et2 la gestion des
catastrophes naturelles
cegid michel doré président du réseau
canadien d'études des risques et dangers
se dorait bonjour bonjour donc bien sûr
vous faites dieu plus que vous occupez
des incendies de forêt les tremblements
terre il ya les inondations bien sûr au
niveau des incendies de forêt j'aimerais
avoir votre impression vos impressions
en tant que spécialiste lorsque vous
avez vu tous ces touristes et tout ces
australiens le long de la corde
surpris par la rapidité la progression
des flammes et les autorités elles mêmes
qui semblaient dépassés
vous êtes dans un scénario connu vous il
faut savoir que les catastrophes
naturelles ont cette caractéristique
commune qu'on parle de temps violent
hivernaux ou de fuites forêt d'affecter
un grand nombre de personnes
simultanément
et quand on dit d'affecter des grands
région ça veut dire à la fois au niveau
des populations au niveau des
infrastructures et toutes les personnes
qui occupent le territoire qu'elles
soient des résidents des travailleurs ou
des touristes vont subir les affres de
ces événements en c'est certain que
qu'on lève
avec les fruits de frontenac marie les
incendies de forêt récurrents que nous
avons non seulement dans l'ouest
canadien mais aussi on en a dans le nord
du québec nous en avons aussi vécu dans
les provinces atlantiques au nouveau
brunswick notamment ce sont toujours des
événements qui viennent frapper à la
fois l'imaginaire et à la fois mené
perturber le fonctionnement d'associer
dans ce genre de situation il ya
évidemment les gouvernements peuvent
générer des capacités importantes pour
essayer de venir en aide aux citoyens
mais les citoyens eux mêmes leur propre
responsabilité dans tout ça et on le dit
aux canadiens dans le cas de tremblement
terre par exemple la région du fleuve
saint laurent à montréal où il pourrait
y avoir un tremblement terre d'une
obscure incroyable aussi grand peut-être
qu'à vancouver ont dit aux citoyens
préparez-vous mais combien de citoyens
se prépare à mettre de l'autre côté de
la nourriture de côté la proportion de
citoyens qui le fait si physiquement
pour les fins de réponse aux
catastrophes est relativement modeste
toutefois on constate à travers les
catastrophes mais vous c'est quand même
ce constant ciel on parle de tremblement
terre dans la région montréal il y en a
eu 1 dont l'épicentre était à einstein
près de 28 dans les derniers jours cette
réalité de la vie n'est habilité
sismiques et aux incendies de forêt ou
autant être violent hivernaux nous
affecte tous au canada pour les
tremblements temps principalement le le
québec et la colombie-britannique est ce
qu'on constate toutefois lors de ces
grands événements c'est que la majorité
de la population est beaucoup plus
résiliente et autonome qu'on peut le
croire
à preuve on se souviendra de la tempête
de verglas de 1998 pp l'est du canada
principalement québec
sur les 5 millions personnes qui ont été
affectées moins de 5% de la population
s'est présenté à un moment ou un autre
dans un centre d'hébergement
c'est donc dire que la population a
cette capacité à se prendre en main mais
le confort et le délai par lequel elles
pourront le faire voir évidemment
améliorée par la préparation initiale de
l'importance des campagnes de
sensibilisation et de préparation du
public on les incite à voir chez eux en
tout temps une trousse 72
nous avons une capacité à maintenir
avant tout un ami pendant 72 heures
qu'est ce qui menace le plus les
citoyens par exemple dans l'est du
canada on va commencer par ceux l'ouest
des scénarios différents bien sûr dans
l'est du canada à ce que c'est forcément
un tremblement terre des incendies de
forêt comme ceux en australie vous qui
devez évaluer les risques qu est ce que
vous avez comme ça comme que vous avez
dessiné sur votre carte dans les grandes
dans la région atlantique
on remarque que les temps les phénomènes
météorologiques sont très importants on
pense notamment aux ouragans
un l'hiver aux tempêtes de neige aux
grandes marées tous fait le même de
l'érosion du littoral qui est exacerbé
évidemment par les grandes campagnes
sont tous des événements qui vont
frapper principalement la côte ouest
l'accord est ce que est ce que vous
pensez qu'on est assez préparés parce
que bon il ya les assurances on essaie
de s'assurer ya stéphane qui disait de
pouvoir toujours penser à ce qui peut
arriver en matière de nourriture ou mais
est ce que est ce qu'on est assez
préparés vraiment la réponse à ça c'est
qu'on est toujours bien préparés pour
les événements que nous avons vécues ou
toutefois le prochain qui s'en vient
sera peut-être d'une nature ou d'une
ampleur différente et ce qui devrait
nous inciter à ne pas baisser la garde
de leurs intérêts par exemple apprendre
des leçons tirer des leçons des grands
événements qui se produisent un peu
partout sur la planète et à cet égard
elle est descendue deux fois répondu au
canada forte mais le riz est ce qu'ils
vivent actuellement en australie sont un
rappel que de se contenter d'être prêt à
répondre aux dernières catastrophes ne
suffit plus d'un contexte évolutif que
l'on connaît évolutif en vain des
changements climatiques mais aussi de
l'évolution de la démographie et de
l'urbanisation sur la planète et bien
entendu la pression que cette
organisation l'or entraîne notamment sur
les infrastructures de qualité et la
préparation aux catastrophes est ce que
c'est juste la responsabilité est
partagée entre l'état et individus mais
le plus gros est ce qui n'est pas au
niveau de l'état pour la préparation
je serais tenter de vous dire que la
plus importante responsabilité en termes
de capacité globale d'une société elle
réside chez les citoyens et elle réside
chez les entreprises parce que si on
demandait à laquelle organisation
étatique que ce soit l'échelle locale
régionale ou nationale de prendre en
charge tous les besoins de base de toute
la population et de répondre à tous les
besoins d'infrastructures
aucune organisation ni arrivait c'est
donc dire que la laisse la population
les familles ont la capacité sont les
premiers acteurs de leur sécurité dans
leurs décisions notamment rester ou de
d'évacuer leur résidence
les autorités vont donner à la
population et aux résidents des
consignes de sécurité parfois des avis
des big d'évacuation et à chaque
événement majeur on remarque de la
population hésite et dans certains corps
retarde sa décision d'évacuation ce qui
vient entraîner des parfois des pertes
humaines malheureusement mais qui vient
aussi compliquer la vie des intervenants
d'urgence
ses doigts côté on veut tenter de
neutraliser les effets de la catastrophe
et de l'autre côté on veut éviter les
conséquences sur les populations à les
évacuer en plus on les évacue de façon
précoce plus ça libère la capacité des
autorités à concentrer ses capacités
opérationnelles sur la neutralisation du
danger je voulais vous poser des
questions sur votre réseau as qui
s'occupe seulement des catastrophes
naturelles ou est-ce que ça s'étend
jusqu'aux catastrophe industrielle ou
deux
le réseau canadien des charges sur les
risques de danger ou le keirin risk and
he has one network en anglais
s'intéressent à tout type de
catastrophes qu'ils soient naturels
technologies qu'ils soient accidentels
ou intentionnels
et quand on parle d'intentionnel on
écrit en incluant évidemment des
attentats terroristes mais on comprendra
que les catastrophes industrielles et
les attentes bien que l on désinfecte kg
pour ceux qui les vivent c'est souvent
en termes de l'espace géographique ce
n'est de durer beaucoup plus courts les
événements météorologiques et matic où
les grands séismes
monsieur doré on voit actuellement ces
images le fuck me croirait en 2016 qui
ont surpris les soyez d'une ville qui
compte peu près 45 mille habitants voyez
les gens qui doivent évacuer la ville
alors que les flammes sont en train de
lécher des camions les véhicules c'est
les gens attendent patiemment font la
file parce que dans l'autre voie on va
laisser passer les véhicules d'urgence
en principe l'on voit que quelques
équipes c'est en semant voilà évidemment
ça des tous les canadiens ont vu ça on a
vu les images aussi en australie d'une
équipe de sapeurs pompiers qui échappe
de justesse de miracle aux flammes et on
a tous à l'idée c'est cette image du
réchauffement planétaire de ces images
apocalyptiques
on se demande bon faisons la part des
choses
est-ce que ça brûle plus maintenant que
ça brûlait dans le passé est ce que le
réchauffement climatique est en train de
se frapper à la porte ou ça fait partie
des des aléas statistiques normaux à ce
moment ci on est tous dans le processus
des incendies de la qualif hors de
l'australie pour tirer des conclusions
faire ferme fois aussi que le changement
climatique augmente les températures
moyennes
on sait aussi que ça vient affecter le
régime des précipitations
c'est à dire que l'on va avoir parfois
des sécheresses plus intenses et dans
d'autres codes et puis beaucoup plus
diluvienne que ce qu'on a déjà connu
dans le passé et ces événements leur
combiné viennent parfois exercice
soit augmenter l'incidence donc le
nombre d'occurrences de ces catastrophes
et dans certains corps d'exacerber leurs
conséquences
ce qu'on voit actuellement en australie
nous laisse entrevoir que les
changements climatiques ont déjà des
répercussions mais pourrait en avoir
encore plus grande de la notre intérêt à
rester vigilants et à se projeter un peu
plus loin que les catastrophes du passé
pour maintenir et développer nos
capacités tant en prévention
quand l'intervention je dors et ce fut
un plaisir de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
l'émission c'est ainsi qu'est que vous
veiller sur nous un peu comme un père de
famille mais évidemment les enfants faut
y mettre tout d'une autre sinon on ira
pas loin à sable en tout cas moi j'ai
retenu les la tronche de 72 heures sans
retenue
je vais aller vérifier merci beaucoup
monsieur doré merci plaisir c'est michel
doré sauver son titre officiel je lis
ici sous les yeux ça m'a impressionné
quand j'ai vu ça mais président du
réseau canadien d'études des risques et
dangers puis ensuite j'ai lu sa
biographie
alors il a une expérience non seulement
pratique ce qu'il a dit hier il était
dans une avec les militaires canadiens
dans une base militaire pour discuter de
ce qu'on pourrait faire scénario ces
choses là
il a une expérience pratique il a été
sous-ministre si même mois et bonnes
années 90 où québec dans le domaine des
urgences c'est un spécialiste a contacté
et il a une expérience soucis au niveau
de l'enseignement il travaille à
l'université du québec à montréal
alors c'est quand même quelques tours et
qui a plus de sens la société en profite
dans tous les sens toujours sait de quoi
il parle voilà ajouté avant d'aller vers
un second invité qui est un spécialiste
des forêts et de l'éco stabilité à terme
que j'invente alors pourquoi pas moi
aussi je suis vraiment loin de la
réalité avec ça j'ai une petite vidéo
vous montre est salée si je vous ai
montré sur l'île de montréal
oui pourrait donner des idées de la
géographie ligne manga 500 kilomètres
carrés
ouais c'est bien on fait bien voici là
je vais vous présenter avant de vous
présenter les questions j'ai une vidéo
faut jamais oublier la vidéo je pense
que c'est sûr voilà c'est la numéro
attendait war données modeuses seconde
sess merci beaucoup c'est la bonne
félicitations à la régie d'être toujours
pour prévenir les mauvais coups alors
voilà alors s'intéresse à la superficie
oui les moyens d'accord pour une
nouvelle économie négoce alors voyons du
jeu de comparaison ils sont 500 km² ma
calculatrice et bien c'est très bien
alors on va afficher la question
maintenant numéro drôle tant la grosse
boule et voici la question au canada
l'équivalent de quel pourcentage de la
superficie de la nouvelle écosse
s'envolent chaque année en fumée ou au
canada l'équivalent de quel pourcentage
de superficie de la nouvelle-écosse
s'envolent chaque année en fumée
borse
ce n'est pas 100% c'est ce que 60
secondes on a décompté partie regarder à
l'écran a donc félicitations à ces
nouveaux merci beaucoup merci ça a
toujours quelque chose est-ce que c'est
25%
faut pas me stresser mais cinq là pour
ça c'est 75% ou dessins pour ça au
canada l'équivalent des parts au temps
de feu comme ça chaque année
oui oui je te mangerais pour faire 5 % à
25 % donc pour a
oui très bien je dirais ce serait triste
à dire mais 100% 100% en espérant que
non vous êtes sûr de sa substance
puisqu'on a eu des feux et j'aimerais
avoir tort vous voulez avoir eu 100% à
l'examen de magritte or ici on perd 30
points ici saison à envoyer là vous
faire des travaux allaient way sens pour
sa conception et sa mise
et voici la bonne réponse on l'a fait
affiches et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
d'eux dans tous les deux vous perdez
donc moi il me reste 50 cent le faire
mais mesdames c'est ça 2 millions 2,5
millions d'hectares de forêts brûlent
par anne et moi je contrôle c'est un art
mais d'autres secteurs c'est parce que
six fois plus grand que mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que là on remarque
c'est pas tous les faits qui font
l'actualité
non finalement administré vu c'est pas
tous les feux qui sont nuisibles non
plus qu'il ya des fenêtres sur elle
ouais il ya les font partie du
renouvellement de la nature et l'étendue
des podcasts pas cela mais il ya des
feux des feux naturels aussi
oui il ya des feux qui permet la
génération en génération regarde système
saint sauveur
c'est naturel au commandant l'australie
par exemple j'avais lu un article très
intéressant dans une publication macro
non les aborigènes depuis des
millénaires font des feux de brousse
pour générer la nature c'est juste que
je n'ai pas de cette ampleur non non et
puis pas de ce n'est pas l'effet des
feux aborigènes qui se
malheureusement il paraît que la
superficie qui brûle au canada est deux
fois plus grande aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était dans les années 70 ça c'est mike
flanagan profil a donné des explications
c'est ça parce que statistiquement
mais ce que c'est pourquoi tout ça ce
serait bien je sais par lg pas mike
flanagan est pas là au bout de 200 m pas
avec nous n'arrêtons professeur
université d'alberta il est pas là mais
en voici un autre visite à l'université
de sherbrooke au québec 40 non pas du
tout il faut donc toujours à poser avec
eux je retrouve chez professeur en
écoconseil au département de science
fondamentale ni merci du québec à
chicoutimi très loin de ça de sherbrooke
professeur boucher bonjour vous avez du
soleil derrière vous vous avez de la
lumière en tout cas chicoutimi vous avez
l'air en forme puis honda bonne humeur
d'être avec nous c'est fantastique
bon écoute et vous là vous êtes un
spécialiste de ces questions de forêt
qui qui sont mal gérés et devraient être
mieux gérer tout ça quand vous voyez ces
feux en australie et quand vous savez
quelle est la situation évolutive au
canada au niveau des incendies de forêt
est-ce que vous établissez des débats
c'est pas des liens oui merci
alors oui mais certainement des liens
dre 6-2 et qu'on le canada il est
distant des pays dans le feu
les feux de brousse le peu de corps et à
son général sont surtout de forêts
seront généralisés ils sont récurrents
sont historiquement présents sur le
territoire via une augmentation qu'on
peut observer lot de l'appétence et
détendue des feux on s'attend ce qu'ils
avaient de les essences forestières pour
la plupart étant donné que c'est une
réalité depuis toujours et des
extensions et celles dont sont adaptés à
certaines risquent donc un feu ne
signifie pas né sur une perte à votre
collègue à votre droite le mentionner
tout à l'heure il ya effectivement une
régénération d'initiés ne représente que
dans bien des cas la plupart des et soit
apps non il s'ensuit une déforestation
l'homme et en l'état des lieux pour
l'australie actuels ne seront sans fin
ce sont des plus
des superficies historique donc jamais
rue y est clair qu'il va y avoir
certainement poursuivre parce que là
c'est pas du tout le territoire et fr
recevoir c'est peu on verra l'état des
lieux par la suite mais peut quand même
comprendre
il ya une bonne part de ces superbes
lots qui vont se régénérer naturellement
ou encore qu'ils le seront par la main
de l'homme parce que ces tribus sont les
territoires et ménagers durablement de
régénérer lorsque monsieur boucher tout
à l'heure mon collègue stéphane avait
parlé vous vous l'avez aussi confirmé
que maintenant le jeu comprend bien la
fréquence des feux augmenté ce qui a une
explication à 100 à ces termes en ont
peut pas associer de manière intime des
changements climatiques mais c'est
clairement un facteur prédominant dans
le sport est aussi dans les productions
dire que le réchauffement climatique de
fait en sorte que les saisons changent
terme de récitation et en terme de durée
et aussi en termes de chaleur que ça
donc ça fait en sorte que des
combustibles c'est le terme qu'on
emploie 1 écologique on est sérieux on
peut les combustibles raisin en forêt
que ce soit la biomasse vivant tout
moment où seules ses combustibles ne
sont plus propices tête brûlée parce
qu'ils y sont généralement plus secte
est aussi il pouvoir qu'il ya une
certaine intensification des phénomènes
climatiques
un choc des extrêmes sont de plus en
plus fréquent donc les orages de plus en
plus fréquents et la conjointe qui
allume les feux en sport consiste du
canada ces termes la cause principale
l'occurrence des feux scellé dans des
fossés la fourrure est donc plus
fréquents pasqua est certainement des
combes ici à être allumées
de sorte que quand monsieur boucher
quand il ya des feux qui touchent des
régions peu ou inhabitable d'accord mais
est ce qu'il ya des craintes aussi que
des feux puisse par exemple se
rapprocher de plus en plus des villes
des maîtres
paul et mettre en danger la vie humaine
au canada oui parce que les petites
mains des communautés proches et il y en
a certains d'étalement urbain aussi un
pouvoir de la conjonction des facteurs
climatiques qui ont leur rôle mais aussi
le facteur humain qui joue c'est à dire
que des populations se rapproche du club
des zones forestières avec cet étalement
urbain que l'on connaît même si le
canada pour une population de phénomène
lost observe donc une conjonction de
facteurs du fait que plus ça va plus les
risques sont élevés par rapport au feu
par rapport à tous les autres risquent
par ailleurs
et puis moi je me pose comme question
les lits tout est question de je sais
qu'il ya des intérêts industriels de
très puissant au canada au niveau de la
fabrication du bois de la coupe du bois
ces choses là et que dans le domaine de
l'environnement dans lequel vous vous
trouvez c'est pas toujours évident
d'essayer d'amener les industries à
accepter la logique de certaines lois
qui devraient être appliquées pour mieux
baliser leur action en forêt
je dis ça avec tous les bémols qu'il
faut un parce que tous beaucoup de
québécois se souviennent d'une de
documentaires incroyable venait
corroborer les roms montréal c'est le
diabète en 99 alors depuis l'erreur
boréale ou la robe l'horreur boréale
quel grand pas avons-nous accompli en
forêt et pas gigantesque un sport pour
le code québec le il dénonce un certain
nombre de choses et qui exprimait aussi
prisé conscience puis des éléments donc
symbolique était très fort on s'est
saisie de ce choc avec bien le dire la
choriste qui a complètement changé
l'homme et non on peut penser que c'est
qu'il faut convaincre lundi où il faut
dompter une industrie
des discours de ce charmant parce que
l'aménagement converser durable du
québec pour l'ensemble canadien mais
pour le québec et de ce que je connais
le mieux
la légende précis durable est entre les
mains du ministère des forêts font débat
et c'est le ministère qui planifie donc
la récolte forestière et qui donc
transmet ensuite aux industriels les
possibilités de récolte et c'est
l'industrie qui se soumet donc on
récupère et on a un cadre législatif de
gouvernance au québec
exemplaire en terme d'aménagement mais
on a atteint un niveau d'intégration de
multiples considérations maintenant dans
l'aménagement forestier qui fait des
jaloux à l'échelle mondiale parce qu'on
considère des éléments dépasse largement
la seule considération de la fibre
ligneuse et met donc deux parties
prenantes peuvent s'exprimer
travailler en amont sur l'aménagement et
avec lui ben des populations et
l'aménagement forestier donc n'est pas
un problème en termes de super la guerre
les perturbations de nature elle dépasse
et de loin de la perturbation casone par
la récolte promet et nous travaillons
avec le canada en entier un seul n'y a
pas de doute là si nous travaillons et
des perturbations naturelles dans la
cadre d'aménagement en faisant partie
dans des facteurs à prendre en
considération dans les ménages vont y
faire face et de réagir une fois que la
tête surface on a su elles ont eu lieu
par des principes d'aménagement qui vont
prévenir et parfois devenir atténuée
donc c'est c'est un facteur d été des
perturbations naturelles en termes de
perturbations la moins importante
perturbation est certainement la mieux
organisée des personnes professeurs on a
une dernière question pour vous écouter
une profession profession boucher vous
dites que expertise québécoise dans
l'aménagement forestier
elle fait des jaloux est ce qui les
inspire ailleurs dans le monde
est ce qu'elle est c'est d'ailleurs dans
le monde la politique québécoise
je pouvais pas vous confirmez vous
donnez des données tangibles
à cet égard mais j'entends des bruits de
témoignages de aménagistes prix
oscillent de personnes dans le coeur des
forêts qui font état de 7 7 à 17 ans qui
se seraient tous fermés aux loisirs mais
sans qualité du management pour les
saisir à témoin de tes moyens de ça nous
sommes le territoire dont le ton de
certification écologique du genre et
normes d'aménagement reconnu
mondialement
cette norme le fc étaient présents de
généreuses et super hitoire québécois
pour ce qui est de l'aménagement
forestier durable et dans la trame
canadien le territoire est resté dans le
monde au lieu au canada
donc nous c'est de cette manière on peut
dire on peut montrer qu'on est
exemplaire vous êtes s'appuie moi j'ai
l'image en tête de l'australie je me
demande si elle s'est montrée exemplaire
dans le passé on a souligné qu'il ya
plusieurs rues et plusieurs
gouvernements conservateurs en australie
qui ont un peu mis de côté les quelques
considérations de d'érosion de sol
l'hydro l'hydro l'hydro il ya des
mouches 25% mais qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'eau en australie défense
disent parce qu'on n'a pas géré le
développement humain correctement et on
ne fait toujours pas bon mais voilà
longtemps dans un autre sujet en fait
parce qu'évidemment territoire
australien canadien alors ils font
partie du covan ou rp2 on peut
contraindre énormément le père de semi
désertique carrément desertec et où les
feux de brousse son être et créer de
forêt productive comme dell mais plus
des feux de brousse et qui occasionnent
dans des enjeux que nous connaissons
il a derrière soi oui effectivement il
est nommé voir des enjeux sont par
exemple du fait de gouvernements actuels
australien et qui va nous être appuyé et
n'agit pas donc dans l'intérêt mondial
une des conséquences attendues des
changements climatiques c'est
l'augmentation des persos va tout
naturellement les frapper de plein fouet
et donc ils goûtent un peu à la médecine
de la question d'adaptation qui rentre
de rang est-ce qu'on doit faire sachant
que ces perturbations ont augment et
nombreux le monde des finances comme le
monde des assurances qui se positionnent
et qu'ils disent
vous pouvez peut être dire que
l'équipement c'est pas des chemins
classiques dépend des réalités mais nous
nous savons que c'est une reine et déjà
comptabilisés et nos projections sont à
l'effet que les coûts reliés aux
assurances et où ce qui les
investissements financiers review
changement climatique et ils vont avoir
un changement il faut son père et de
toute manière et la facture votre
rigueur filets face à bush et merci
beaucoup de nous avoir aidés aujourd'hui
dans notre réflexion sur ce qu'on fait
bien est ce qu'on fait on pourrait mieux
faire
on peut pas dire qu'on fait du bon
parfois des séquelles ans était jean
françois professeur en écoconseil au
département de sciences fondamentales à
l'université du québec à chicoutimi dans
la belle province du québec
je voulais juste revenir sur le
gouvernement australien
il y avait beaucoup été dit que c'était
un gouvernement climato-sceptiques
conservateur or qu'il est libéral
ah oui c'est ça paraît paradoxal par
rapport à l'idée reçue comme ça on
parlait aussi des gouvernements
précédents qui étaient conservateurs
malheureusement ça en prend toujours un
ou deux et puis pendant les feux le
premier ministre actuel du premier
ministre était quand même en vacances à
hawaï et c'est vrai donc écoutez je
voulais presse vous vous souvenez des
deux premières questions des questions
de superficie 5000 kilomètres carrés de
la nouvelle écosse avant d'aller dans
notre dernier je ne veux avoir de quoi
vider au numéro 8
pour en savoir plus sur ce sujet on va
passer rapidement on va vous montrer ce
qu'il ya ce qui accompagne la page le
sonore et visuelle aujourd'hui
l'émission alors voilà c'est tout c'est
tout la haye-du-puits récent au plus
anciens on n'a pas parlé beaucoup des
tremblements terre amie big one de moi
j'ai ressenti le jeu santé l'avait ça
j'étais je te lèves tôt j'étais devant
mon ordinateur je sais pas sur facebook
en tout cas c'est heureux et j'ai sauté
je me suis dit j'ai et je me suis dit
quoi c'est un camion j'ai pensé à un
camion et puis mais ça m'a effleuré
l'idée que c'est un tremblement de terre
puis puis c'est parti et puis tout d'un
coup je reçois de du marc de mon
quartier une alerte twitter qui dit vrai
vous avez formé il était debout
alors voilà pour si vous voulez vous
lire la suite parce que nous on n'a pas
le temps alors je compte dessus et un
troisième jeu de la grosse boule la wii
le temps dans des boules à l'émission
allons-y on avait perdu 70 ans de perdus
il me reste est perdu 30 seulement
martin 62 cents
alors voici la question vous vous
souvenez du test le test de maths à
ouidah corps à corps la superficie de
nouvelle écosse là il va falloir et
combien de fois celle de l'île de
montréal
la superficie la nouvelle écosse et
combien de fois celle de l'île de
montréal
c'est joli ça comme question ouais
personne ne se pose ce genre de question
non alors pourquoi pas la pause et
pourquoi pas moi je dirais 110 x 110 x
ou y penser si les feux 50 % des
superficies ou et de la nouvelle écosse
a pas de corrélation non d'accord
je comprends ça se voit j'essaie de
faire si on a eu une inconnue l'île de
montréal 6 500 kilomètres carrés
d'accord et puis on avait dix ans dix
fois 500 km² c'était la superficie qui
brûlent présentement en australie un
indice
donc c'est que cette fois là non on n'a
pas 10 à 50%
oui donc c'est sordide bon à autre chose
qu'à une minuterie à cette question
alors vous répondez quoi vite les 110 x
110 x b pour conserver tout bon point
samir vous répondez quoi vous avez
échoué à 70 fois parce que sinon ça le
chiffre va augmenter b et oui c'est ça
des fois vous avez tous raison à merci
parce que ça va augmenter
ah non mills horaires ça va aller voter
oui c'est possible c'est quand même
rentrer alors là les superficies des
banques je garde c'est 50 points ça va
même fille station cinquante cinq mille
kilomètres carrés c'est la super six des
neuf et les casses et la belgique c'est
à peu près un peu plus quelques rythmes
lents la belgique je savais pas c'est
très graphique 1 c'est pas le
liechtenstein censure c'est pas le
vatican
j'essaie de me souvenir la première
question à vous disait que on avait
combien de fois la superficie de l'île
de montréal
c'est bien c'est 200 % 2 200 points wii
bondues ont su perdre les questions de
mathématiques chose qui a pas de
quatrième question parce que je serais
même paul je serais même pas laquelle
vous reposer voilà on est prêt pour le
dernier jeu de l'émission oui c'est quoi
un canton ce sens c'est ça ouais bah
plus que ça c'est plus digne d'une photo
c'est l'image et moi pardon il
image de la sema s'user pardon c'est le
compromis je répond par oui ou par non
seulement vous décidez de existe le
crash de l'avion mais enfin le en iran
non parce que ça je pense que la gauche
a fait qu est-ce qu on nettoie les
pingouins que du joug de
de calgary brinon qu'est ce qu'on a
est-ce que c'est pas être dicté le tempo
la destitution de m
non à la journée à mada oui ok en partie
là les martyrs au nom de quoi le chemin
ressent en partie pinon parti à bâle âge
elle a vraiment quoi qu'est-ce qu'on
avait ce qui s'est passé on est passé
des choses
toute la semaine on était faux que se
faisait pas beaucoup de questions c'est
non balla en politique québécoise de
serre liées à la politique ça demain
trudeau non non klimato un climato
sceptiques oui il ya un rapport de la
nasa
le rapport la nasa et de la noaa qui est
l' agence des océans des états unis là
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit cette semaine
est le réchauffement
ouais des océans ben non de la dernière
décennie un qui était la plus chaude
voilà l'histoire une histoire et
s'accompagner par suicide images oui
c'est une image vaut mille mots surtout
dans les articles récents articles à la
photo au fait que news de l'australie
qui brûle tout l'australie qui brûlent
quittera y répondre mais c'est bien
connu
puis plus clair les seuls autres années
parmi les 10 premières
parce qu'on en a huit des dix premières
à voir 2010c'est 2005 et de 1998 qui ont
été les plus chaudes
voilà au niveau des centres socialement
l'année où il y avait le vent
oui ça a mal commencé ça s'est mal
terminée comme ça va l'impressionner
tout est lié tout est lié aux fonderies
quelque part alors on n'oublie pas notre
trousse 72 heures c'est ça ouais ça je
me sentais bien après qu'est ce que vous
mettez dans votre trousse de 72 à des
coachs vers leurs prières oui 63 ça me
remercie beaucoup détruire six semaines
et puis ça elle aussi ismaël et ceux qui
croient c'est vrai avant l'admission et
on commence
[Rires]